ramaswami posted this over the weekend
this tweet he says on day one instantly
fire 50% of federal bureaucrats here's
how if your social security number ends
in an odd number you're fired that
downsizes government by half absolutely
nothing will break as a result it
doesn't violate civil services rules
because Mass layoffs are exempt shut it
down then he continued to elaborate this
avoids Civil Service protections no
bureaucrat can claim their firings were
politically motivated further firings
can be executed with a chisel but step
one needs to be an unrestrained chainsaw
or else just won't happen now this
plan's getting a you know reaction from
people online and first let me just say
that the idea that we should just fire
50% of federal bureaucrats is totally
outrageous and insane and I agree a lot
with a lot of what ramas Swami says but
this is just nonsense 50% it should be
90%